so this is Ralph Hilton I'm the creative
director on Forza horizon 2 which is
coming exclusively to Xbox this is
September 30th I'm today we're talking
about just I open the the massive open
world of Forza horizon 2 AIDS
so it's not just a bit roids this time
it's also about the countryside you can
leave their order any point you can
smash through a fence drive across field
through a vineyard over a hill it's
really up to you how you use the open
world move self loads and loads of
really great events challenges within
the world for you to find there for you
to complete one of which is the bucket
less challenges which we're looking at
right now each of them set up to utilize
the car that you found at a particular
area of the world that you found it so
this just shows just how open the world
is at one moment you'll be driving on
the motorway or a lot of Road the next
you'll be crashing through a forest
through a venue area over a hill and
what it does has really changed the way
you play the game and suddenly you'll be
making your own routes choosing quick
shortcuts you want to take an explorer
in the world to its fullest